foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
what a thrill
darkness and silence through the night
[Music]
searching and I'll melting to you
what a fear in my heart
this is cited in Queens causing it now
cover the door the
be anywhere
[Music]
leave Connor alone
to hunt I'll give him one he'll never
forget
he's gonna wish he never came to New
York
triangulating positions
Target located at Harlem Fish Market all
teams converge lizards across the river
I'm not gonna make it in time
foreign
the hunters tracked Connors to the
Harlem fish market
dessert
sounds like Craven's checking off his we
don't have much time move
uh guess we'll chat later
Genki the lizard's loose at the fish
market must be Sushi night you still got
the hunter drone you hijacked and really
tough hiding it for my mom but yeah I'll
boot up and see you there
they got here fast
stop
can't let them find Connors or he's done
for it
[Music]
spread out it's if you find the lizard
don't engage alone
[Music]
fish
it's been feeding
I never saw a couple
[Music]
so how's the hunt going watch out guys
scheduled by the three tons of dead fish
not well
where are you Connors
garage might lead to him
Connor's tore through this place
out of control
all right
[Music]
where am I now
how'd you find me the fish
drones picking up lizards Trail
he's still eating we can catch him off
guard
Yankee get behind me
it's just his skin
doesn't that mean he's getting bigger
[Music]
hungrier too
come on
whoa amen
new threads the building's swarming with
Hunters any sign of Connors uh yeah
genki's tracking him hey Mr Parker
Mr Spider-Man I mean
but the date is incomplete
okay I think I got a lock did you wait
you chill
that wasn't me me neither
I don't even have a stomach so
let's go
go go make him alive
you can't lose counters Harry's dying
and he's the only one who can help we
won't you take the Drone I got the jet
skis
if I borrow this
this is really really exciting keep it
tight man watch out for those drones
don't worry they think I'm a friendly
each river is not a river but in fact a
saltwater title flat Spiderman is
fighting on right now
help the tour boat right I've got the
metal murder bird
I warned you about going after Connor's
now this is on you
clouds that all you got
almost done here civilians are all safe
how you looking
gunship won't quit I'm right behind you
we'll take it down together no time
I got you time to go boom boys no no
Spider-Man it's good defenses
Spider-Man hang on
over there
[Music]
let's go
come on let's go
it's right behind you I know I know whoa
Steve Master fly faster
I do not want to be lizard food
Ed
okay get him hold on
everyone take cover
what are you guys doing trying to take
out that gunship can't get close enough
but I can I'm one of them remember bro
that's it hey alley-oop on three pi
one two three Ally
he got away from us
it's good Pete
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no
mine
sure
it's got big teeth so do I
um he's not normally like that right
no
he's never like that
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I write to escape
every word is a step forward
the darkness
I'm glad you're on this case with me
Anderson
it's right up your alley
the victim was one of their own FBI
special agent Robert Nightingale
so you knew Al victim only the rumors he
was chasing a writer
someone knew they were here was playing
a game with them
killer left the message
it's for us
the text is about us
we were all trapped in a horror story
The Horror Story wanted us dead
there's something I forget it
something important
something's not right
easy now
first things first what's your name
[Music]
[Applause]
what blind marches on
these people live with a knife to their
throat you have to believe us we'd help
you if we could
your help your house already
we never asked to be saved did you think
we'd thank you they'll never forgive us
we're all marked now
every time you show your faces it is we
who suffer
[Music]
Jeff he better hope so
crystals take more than they give you
mean to tell me that the mother crystals
are the reason the world is dying
thank you tell we're talking if they
won't give us a say we'll decide our
Fates another way
Tell Me True do you believe what I'm
about to do is wrong I was forced to
kill you do it by choice
you believe in me they believe in the
power of the dominant you Can't Blame A
man who wanted to bring it into all this
can you ever LED astray by your blind
resolve and thus is the fight
we don't need your salvation
we'll save ourselves and we'll do it on
our own towns
who are we what are the dominance we are
but Mighty acts of God enough of this I
use my talents to my advantage you would
tell me there is shame in that we we
shared a dream I would be the king of
the world darkness is
I made a promise to my friends and it is
they who will give me the strength to
lend your Reign your efforts will Avail
us not
the fight we survive we enjoy we don't
need a reason
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
oh
we need to find a way to get you inside
without being seen
you could bribe the guards to look the
other way I shall see what flavor best
suits me
[Music]
embrace the fear
quiet it find the Stillness
let's go
the stage is your spasm
we will be watching
[Music]
not remember then have we forgotten that
you've protected me from the dragon's
flames you need only believe in your own
destiny there is a force that begs the
question if he's a mere Mama then where
might our true and risen than for
snedinia's life is in your hands sir
praise be for only the sovereign's
Guidance the leaders
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I've crossed paths with many during my
journey for True strength
I've also met my share of enemies
I had to overcome
my journey knows no end I will continue
to do what I have always done
when you said you were seeking strength
despite having no real need to do so
honestly I thought you were a complete
idiot
last
Master he was set up
[Music]
I'm not nearly strong enough to chase
after a monster like that
[Music]
it's probably worth looking into this
nice shawl business
[Music]
es
he attempted to set the world under his
field through violence
a veritable madman
when you go looking for strength it's
not like a game
this journey doesn't have a reality
[Music]
Street Fighter 6
.
[Music]
thank you
welcome back for another week of career
fulfillment and minimal social
interaction
we know how challenging it can be to
find a place where you feel that you
truly belong and to find a job that
treats you mostly with respect and only
infrequently with contempt
for that reason we are excited to inform
you that you did an adequate enough job
the first time around to have you back
also there were no other applicants so
strap yourself in and get motivated to
an appropriate degree
see nothing yet
[Music]
foreign
how far can you have gone
passenger
[Music]
foreign
you've missed so much
we're flame gods
Vanquish nightmares
fought alongside those who we once
fought against
I wish you could have been there
[Music]
me too kiddo
but hey I'm here now
wherever the hell here is
[Music]